A fraction of a second ago, the electricity
powering your lights, your air conditioning,
your television, your refrigerator, nearly
everything electric around you right now,
was water, gas, wind, or some other form of
energy, potentially hundreds or thousands
of miles away.
If you flip a light switch in Los Angeles,
that could cause a turbine in Washington to
start spinning.
Electric grids are considered some of the
single largest machines in existence—they
stretch across entire continents—but they’re
machines with absolutely zero slack.
With water systems, for example, there’s
some extra supply in a storage reservoir at
the treatment plant, and some extra supply
in the pipes connecting the treatment plant
to your home—supply only has to roughly
match demand—but that’s not the case with
electricity.
Your lights, your TV, your microwave—everything
plugged into the grid uses electricity produced
just moments ago.
For the sake of example, let’s look at what
it takes to turn on the lights at the public
library in the small town of Glenwood Springs,
Colorado.
Now, what makes the relatively straightforward
task of converting natural fuels or phenomena
into electric power difficult is the huge
variability in demand from minute-to-minute
and month-to-month.
There are, however, some trends.
On an annual basis, the peaks correlate to
climate—January represents the winter high-water
mark as many homes and businesses turn on
their electric heating, while July typically
ranks highest outright as the country battles
summer heat with air conditioners.
The month-to-month variations are not that
significant, though—the difference between
the highest and lowest demand months is less
than a third.
Most of the variability happens across a given
day.
In January, all regions of the US observe
a two-peak daily demand trend, where electricity
use spikes around 7:00 AM as people turn up
their thermostats and fire up lights and appliances
as they wake up and get ready for the day.
Then, demand peaks again when people return
from work in the evening and do the same.
Meanwhile, in July, energy use is highest
in the late-afternoon or early-evening, but
this does depend on the region.
For example, in the sweltering Southwest,
usage peaks around 4:00 pm—around the hottest
hour of the afternoon, when air conditioners
have to work the hardest.
In the more temperate northwest, though, which
includes Colorado and that Glenwood Springs
public library, fewer buildings have air conditioning
so demand peaks around 6:00 pm—pulled back
by post-work use of appliances, lights, televisions,
and more.
These trends then get further complicated
by holidays and special events—for example,
on Superbowl Sunday in the US, demand plummets
for a few hours as people turn off the lights,
stop cooking, and gather together at others’
homes to watch the big game.
This is all to say, when forecasting demand,
utilities need to factor in the hour, day,
season, location, and plenty more.
Now, with whatever demand materializes, utilities
then need to essentially instantly match supply.
To do this, they layer different energy sources
on top of each other.
Often, the lowest layer is Nuclear Power.
Nuclear power stations aren’t designed to
be able to turn off and on easily—it would
take the better part of a day to shutdown
and start up again—so it’s rather impractical
to operate these in response to demand.
In addition, considering how massively expensive
their construction is, it would economically
inefficient to let these stations run idle.
Therefore, they’ll run nearly continuously
for the entirety of their service lives, except
for during planned maintenance.
This means they provide the most stable supply
of electricity 24/7.
Colorado no longer operates any nuclear power
plants, but it does have six of the next layer—coal
power stations.
Like nuclear, most of these coal plants cannot
be fired up quickly, as they take some time
to get up to temperature, so utilities will
also run them essentially continuously.
Coal and nuclear combined typically fulfill
what’s called the base-load.
Their continuous production essentially equals
the valley of demand—they’ll make the
minimum amount of power needed at a point
in the day.
So then, on top of that, utilities need production
methods that can fire up and shut down far
faster—they need to be able to produce the
power to operate all those AC units in hot
summer afternoons.
The bulk of this job is completed by natural
gas fired plants.
Of the 25 in Colorado, 13 of these stations
generate using a simple cycle combustion turbine.
This is the simplest means of turning natural
gas into electricity—much like a jet engine,
the fuel is used to turn a turbine, which
turns a generator, which produces electricity.
More advanced natural gas power plants recover
the hot exhaust to convert it into electricity
too, but the startup process for these takes
longer, so simple cycle stations are used
for applications where speed is key.
Most can reach full power within 15 minutes,
making them an effective tool to respond to
those short peaks in demand.
Nuclear, coal, and natural gas are some of
the more traditional means of generating electricity.
The recent proliferation of renewable energy
sources, though, has kickstarted an reinvention
of this system of base-load and peaker plants.
That’s because, when wind and solar generating
stations can make power, that power is essentially
free—meaning there’s essentially no additional,
variable cost to generate power once the panels
or turbines are installed.
That’s not the case with natural gas fired
plants, for example, as the gas itself represents
one of their primary costs.
So, this essentially creates a new bottom
layer to the energy mix—but it’s a bottom
layer that’s uncontrollably variable.
One sunny, windy day could mean that a state
has an excess of electricity when added to
its base-load sources, while one cloudy, windless
day could mean that the peaker plants have
to operate at full force.
Solar and onshore wind power are now some
of the cheapest sources of electricity, but
because they rely on natural phenomena, they
can’t match supply to demand the way that
the traditional nuclear, coal, natural gas
trifecta can.
Therefore, grids are being reinvented so that
supply doesn’t have to match demand—at
least minute-to-minute.
Of course, the way to do that is with storage,
but storing electricity is not easy.
The average American household uses about
30 kilowatt-hours of electricity per day.
Lithium-ion batteries currently cost around
$130 per kilowatt-hour, meaning one-day’s
storage for one household would cost around
$3,900 in batteries—and that’s excluding
all the additional infrastructure needed to
make such an installation possible.
Considering the average American household
pays less than half that per year in electricity
bills, installing such a system grid-wide
would be economically impractical.
Nonetheless, Colorado has four battery-electric
storage systems—albeit it at a relatively
minor scale.
The largest of which is used to power Fort
Carson—a US army base near Colorado Springs.
They charge up the 8.5 megawatt battery at
night, when electricity demand, and therefore
rates, are low, then use the power during
the day when the majority of the base’s
electricity use occurs.
The system’s savings should make up for
its installation cost in about 13 years, then
by the end of its practical lifespan it’s
expected to have saved the army about half
a million dollars in electricity costs.
While such a system can make economic sense
for large complexes that can invest in infrastructure
that won’t pay off for more than a decade,
it’s just not practical grid-wide—at least
right now.
Even if there was the battery production capacity
to make a meaningful dent in the world’s
electricity use, the savings just happen too
far in the future for most to consider such
storage to be worth it.
However, for entirely different reasons, in
the coming decades, more and more people will
be purchasing massive battery packs—the
ones inside their EVs.
With most forecasts suggesting that some third
of new car sales in the US will be electric
by 2030, a potential solution to the grid’s
storage need could arise naturally.
A Rivian R1T, for example, holds a 135 kilowatt-hour
battery pack, meaning it could, theoretically,
power the average American household for four
and a half days.
While EV’s typically take in electricity,
little stands in the way technologically from
them giving that electricity back to the grid.
So, the idea is that EV’s could charge at
night or when renewables are performing well,
then supply some of that electricity back
to the grid during the day while parked and
plugged in.
In exchange, vehicle owners would be compensated
a small amount by the utility company.
While the real-world, wide-scale economics
have yet to be proven, especially in the face
of battery degradation, this vehicle-to-grid
concept could potentially play a cooperative
role in the transition towards a greener grid.
Now, the largest current battery electric
storage system in Colorado, the Fort Carson
installation, has 8.5 megawatts of capacity.
Elsewhere in the state, however, there’s
a massive, different form of battery can can
power over 10,000 homes at once—and it looks
like this.
Water is one of the earliest forms of energy
that humans harnessed, and it still represents
one of the best sources of electricity.
Hydroelectric power is the best of both worlds.
While there’s certainly the potential for
environmental damage from damming up rivers,
the carbon impact is near-zero, meaning hydro
is green like wind and solar.
However, it’s also reliable.
In theory, hydroelectric dams can start and
stop making power in minutes—even if in
practice a minimum flow is typically maintained—so
they can operate like those natural gas, single-cycle
peaker plants, responding to demand.
Of course, there’s only so much water upstream—especially
in a place like Colorado, which is in the
midst of a 20-year-long drought—but hydroelectric
dams simply convert potential energy into
electric energy.
There’s no reason why that process can’t
happen in reverse.
That’s what happens here, at the Cabin Creek
Generating Station.
When electricity’s cheap—typically at
night, or when wind and solar are performing
at their peak—the facility uses it to pump
water to its upper, higher-elevation reservoir.
Then, when electricity’s expensive and in
demand, like in the late afternoon, it will
start flowing that water through its turbines,
out into its lower reservoir.
It’s essentially a form of price arbitrage,
but its one that’s already helping smooth
out the peaks and valleys of wind and solar
power production.
Now, no matter how well supply is matched
to demand, electricity is of no use to that
Glenwood Springs, Colorado library until,
of course, it gets there.
Many have an image of power plants as something
sitting just outside every town and city.
While that’s how the earliest grids operated,
it’s hardly the case anymore.
Despite dramatic declines in the past decade,
some 42% of Colorado’s power supply still
comes from coal.
That means that nearly half of the state’s
electricity originates from, essentially,
just six sites—the state’s coal power
stations.
Therefore, the ability to efficiently transport
electricity over a long distance is essential.
Now, what makes long-distance transmission
tricky is simple: the further you send electricity,
the more you lose along the way—typically
through unavoidable conversion to heat.
Meanwhile, the more centralized your electricity
production, the less it costs—it’s simple
economies of scale.
Therefore, the task of transmission is all
about balancing these competing effects to
find an equilibrium.
Now, houses, businesses, and other buildings
connected to the electric grid all use alternating
current power.
A big reason why this standard beat out its
direct current competitor in the days of Tesla,
Westinghouse, and Edison is because it’s
relatively easy to convert AC power between
higher and lower voltages using transformers.
What makes this crucial is that the higher
the voltage, the less electricity lost during
transmission.
Specifically, a doubling in voltage quarters
the power loss in transmission.
That relatively simple voltage transformation
allows for a more efficient electricity distribution
system.
Colorado’s second largest power plant is
this: the Craig Generating Station.
It connects to some of the state’s highest
voltage transmission lines—two of which
head due south until the town of Rifle.
Now, these lines operate at 345 kilovolts,
which means that, in theory, over the 75 mile
or 120 kilometer stretch from Craig to Rifle,
about 3.2% of the electricity is lost—a
relatively minor amount, thanks to the efficiency
of high-voltage transmission.
Other more densely populated regions, which
need more electric transmission capacity,
have even higher voltage lines, all the way
up to 765 kilovolts—the current highest
voltage transmission standard in the US.
Quite few of these lines exist in the US—there’s
one connecting Quebec to New York State, and
then a larger system spanning between Illinois
and Virginia.
These can carry about six times as much electricity
as the 345 kilovolt line between Craig and
Rifle and, thanks to their high voltage, see
as little as 0.6% loss per 100 miles or 160
kilometers.
That means that, in theory, assuming the infrastructure
existed, a 765 kilovolt line could transmit
electricity from New York to LA, and about
87% of it would still be there at the other
end.
That’s why these high-voltage lines are
becoming more and more common.
But what’s even more efficient than transmitting
an alternating current at a super high voltage
is transmitting a direct current.
Of course, the difficulty with direct current
is that transforming it between voltages is
more expensive than with AC, and for use in
today’s grid, it has to be converted to
AC power, which is also expensive.
However, compared to the absolute lowest 0.6%
loss per 100 miles with the highest voltage
AC lines, DC lines see as little as 0.45%
loss per 100 miles.
Therefore, when there’s a need to transmit
a huge amount of electricity over a long distance,
the economics can work in favor of converting
power to DC at its origin, and converting
it back to AC at its destination.
Perhaps the most prominent application of
such a system in the US is the Pacific DC
Intertie, stretching between northern Oregon
and Los Angeles, California.
In the summer, the temperate northwest has
relatively little power demand, but generates
a huge amount of cheap electricity thanks
to its hydroelectric dams.
So, the Pacific DC Intertie sends this electricity
south to power Los Angeles’ air conditioners
during its hot summer.
Meanwhile, in the winter, Los Angeles sees
temperate weather and little need for climate
control, so it sends its excess electricity
north to the Pacific Northwest to power its
electric heating.
Phenomena like this demonstrate why creating
a greener, more efficient grid involves a
proliferation of long-distance power transmission
infrastructure—its needed to balance out
seasonal trends, and to bring power from where
it can be produced easily to where it cannot.
Back in Colorado, though, its relatively minor
345 kilovolt line from the Craig Power Station
eventually enters this more-populated area
flanking Interstate 70.
Here, there are a number of nearby towns that
need electricity, but sending 345 kilovolts
to each of these would not be efficient.
That’s simply because the higher the voltage,
the higher the construction cost.
A 345 kilovolt substation might cost $10.7
million, while a 230 kilovolt one just $7.6
million.
Meanwhile, a 345 kilovolt line costs around
$4.5 million per mile to build, while a 230
kilovolt line just $2.8 million.
Therefore, even though the transmission losses
will be greater, a number of substations around
Rifle transform the electricity to 230 kilovolts,
and then smaller, cheaper lines carry the
flow west, south, and east, closer to its
final customers.
About 30 miles or 50 kilometers to the east,
this line encounters another substation, which
steps it down to just 69 kilovolts and then
another yet smaller line circles back towards
Glenwood Springs.
The power is then stepped down again to 12.47
kilovolts, before a final transformer converts
it to 120, 240, or 480 volts—the voltages
used by almost all buildings in the US, including
the public library of Glenwood Springs, Colorado.
Unlike with electricity, the supply of domain
names is stable—there’s only one wendoverproductions.com,
for example—even as demand grows and grows.
There are now more websites on the internet
than ever before—around 2 billion—so if
there’s even a chance you will want to make
one in the future, now is the time to buy
your domain, before its gone.
Our sponsor, Hover, makes that incredibly
easy.
Whether you want the domain corresponding
to your name, your business, your YouTube
channel, or anything else, Hover makes finding
it super simple, and you can even get extra
creative and stand out with their over 400
domain extensions—like I did with our wendover.productions
domain.
Plus, with your new, custom domain, Hover
can set up up a custom email address in seconds,
meaning you can stand out with a firstname@lastname.com
email address, for example.
Hover also has super-fair, transparent pricing,
and truly awesome customer support, making
them definitively the best place to go to
get your domain.
There’s a reason why I’ve bought every
domain of mine through Hover, and you can
too for 10% off by clicking the button on-screen
or heading to Hover.com/Wendover, and you’ll
be helping support the channel while you’re
at it.